bonjour je suis tel c'est ensemble que
nous allons découvrir l'histoire du
soulier
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dans histoire de souliers
nous vous proposons un épisode tout à
fait spéciale en effet pas de
présentation d'un modèle de chaussures
en particulier mais nous allons
justement nous intéresser aux chaussures
inclassable qu'elle soit complètement
excentriques ou sur mesure
ce qui n'est pas contradictoire vous
découvrirez ces modèles de chaussures
d'exception à travers les théories et
les expériences de nos professionnels de
la confection de chaussures
il vous révéleront qu'elle pourrait être
selon eux la chaussure de l'avenir vous
apprendrez également comment se déroule
en détail la fabrication d'un modèle sur
mesure avec le très précieuses images
d'un atelier historique et enfin nous
vous présenterons les modèles
inclassable issus de la haute couture et
du design
[Musique]
c'est en plein coeur de paris non loin
de la place vendôme que nous retrouvons
philippe atienza directeur de l'atelier
séculaire d'un grand nom de la chaussure
ayant collaboré avec chanel nous leur
entre eux il est depuis sa jeunesse un
spécialiste de la chaussure sur mesure
[Musique]
préférez-vous concevoir la chaussures
masculines ou féminines une question
difficile dans la mesure où j'ai
travaillé pendant très longtemps dans
une maison où la spécialité était la
chose sur masculine donc on s'imprègne
forcément du goût du style de la maison
et par compte revenir à la chaussure
féminine était plutôt un retour à ce que
j'ai mais avant ce qui fait que c'est
plutôt un complément ses deux métiers
qui sont bien différents par les
techniques parler par le test le goût la
sensibilité des produits qu'on va
utiliser des matières premières et puis
aussi de la façon d'approcher le
chaussant parce que pour une chaussure
femme il ya une cambrure pointures
seront beaucoup moins et donc une
préférence pas vraiment une attirance
pour les deux
assurément comme vous l'aurez compris
monsieur etienne à sait de quoi il parle
nous lui demandons donc de nous
expliquer étape par étape comment se
déroule la création d'une chaussure sur
mesure nous sommes alors invités à le
suivre à l'atelier de fabrication en
prenant 10 mais tout d'abord allons voir
du côté de nos autres professionnels de
la chaussure pour des précisions
supplémentaires
[Musique]
m
pour moi la chaussure le plus les
inclassables ou le plus original c'est
la mairie d'orchies
donc j'aime ces spirales jeu les vues
sur pied je les achetez moi même je
trouve qu'un objet et les magnifiques si
aupiais il est joli et bizarrement se
rendre dans son quotidien pour aller
plus loin dans les centres is it et de
la chaussure je dirais qu aujourd'hui on
peut pas on a les chaussures sans talons
on a les chaussures qui sont très
habillé on est allé très loin dans les
nouveaux matière donc pour moi cette
courbe et finit par contre quelque chose
côté et centre est qui va nous
intéresser s'électrise ation de nos
chaussures
donc je sais très bien que je veux
mettre une pile très léger dans la
chaussure ou dans mon talon il y à des
applications web qui peuvent être
développées autour de ça il y à
l'électricité donc pour moi les choses
que je vais regarder très étroitement
dans l'avenir de cette marque c'est du
fos ference d'électricité des choses qui
brillent ou des choses qui me
communiquent par exemple qui me disent
que j'ai pris une 200 grammes dans la
journée ou que j'ai fait une certaine
nombre de pas donc je pense que cet
excentrique citait création est
aujourd'hui quasiment fini les
frontières ont été poussés et le marché
n'a pas été là donc je pense qu'on
revient beaucoup sur des ballons
de retour avec philippe atienza pour la
découverte de l'atelier de fabrication
leur rôle en cela ne sera pas sans
réaliser une petite visite des archives
des moules d'escarpins sur mesure c'est
une chance énorme de se retrouver au
milieu de tous ces modèles uniques vous
pouvez rentrer donc dans cet atelier
pour fabriquer nos chaussures une
dizaine d'artisans travail sachant qu'il
y a chacun ils ont tous plus ou moins
une spécialité
oui vous ne me raconter le processus de
fabrication sur mesure
je vais essayer de vous le raconter en
partant de la 1re étape 1 donc la prise
de mesures la mesure donc sa mesure du
pied on pose le pied de la cliente ou du
client sur une feuille de papier on
trace le pourtour et on relève les
mesures principales au niveau des doigts
à coups de pieds mesure d'entrée partant
de là on réalise un moule angoua semoule
est adapté aux mesures de la cliente ou
du client pour une femme la cambrure est
extrêmement importante sachant que c'est
ce qui va définir le confort de la
chaussure et puis définir la hauteur du
talon évidemment ensuite en termes
esthétiques ce qui est important c'est
le bout de le bout de la forme parce que
vous pouvez avoir une forme pointue une
forme ronde ou plus courte et c'est au
moment du travail de forme qu'on définit
tout ça c c'est ce qui donne les
premières lignes de la chaussure
réalisée on doit pour un client mesures
réaliser un essayage l'essayage c'est
une maquette qui va venir confirmer le
travail de forme
si la forme est suffisamment confortable
en terme de show 100 pour le client ou
la cliente
une fois que ce travail de deux
d'essayage et réaliser on peut passer à
l'étape suivante qui consiste à faire la
paire de chaussures réel et la paire de
chaussures et elle sait plusieurs
métiers avant de découvrir en détail
l'ensemble des artisans nécessaires à la
création de la chaussure sur mesure
retrouvons juliette et alma et propose
elle aussi des chaussures entièrement
personnalisable jusqu'à la fantaisie et
pouvant tout simplement être commandé en
ligne
où trouvez vous l'inspiration pour créer
de nouvelles formes et choisir de
nouvelles matières alors c'est tout
simple c'est dans la rue voilà toutes
les femmes vous inspire on les regarde
énormément
d'ailleurs des fois on se prend des jo
les réflexions mais vrai qu'on regarde
les pieds de tout le monde c'est à dire
qu'on va voir passer une femme devant
nous a vraiment la relooker pour le coup
mais c'est ce qui nous inspire c'est à
dire quand les tendances sont dans la
rue vraiment bon évidemment après dans
les magazines et les nouvelles tendances
voient là d'année en année on les trouve
aussi dans les magazines c'est vrai mais
les citoyenne lambda nous inspire
énormément et on suit plaisir us
oui c'est vrai voilà notamment la low
boots était vraiment un plaisir
personnel
dalmat et moi on avait envie d'avoir une
low boots du coup on s'est créé notre le
foot
voilà c'est aussi un c'est un peu
égoïste à la base
évidemment on s'amuse aussi on fait des
choses sur quand même aucune manière de
réaliser vos propres envies ce que vous
me trouvez ça en boutique et voilà tout
à fait et on a aussi tellement deux
auteurs de talent différentes que chaque
femme peut trouver son bonheur chez nous
dira si on part sur 1,6 cm talons épais
on
et on a l'impression d'être à plat alors
qu'on est en talons on a un confort
unique le 8 cm aussi est idéal et je
pense qu'elles recherchent vraiment le
confort et en même temps bien sûr le
côté complètement délirant de la
personnalisation là quand même à peu
près entre 100 et 120 couleurs et
matières différentes
donc on peut vraiment aller jusqu'au
bout de ses envies et de ses fantasmes
et c est en même temps en alliant le
confort et je pense que ça c'est un vrai
gage de qualité et une vraie envie de
notre part de pouvoir donner et alliés
c'est de ces deux points là très
important d'accord et vous qui voyez
passer les commandes des clientes
est ce que vous voyez des clientes qui
n'osent par la fantaisie qui vont y
rester je suis un écrivain vraiment sûr
plein mais en même temps il ya des
clientes qui viennent chez nous parce
qu'elles recherchent justement le
savoir-faire de tradition et de confort
donc elles vont pas forcément venir chez
nous pour la personnalisation elles vont
faire des escarpins qui sont assez
sobres nous escarpins noirs avec des
petites touches de blanc mais parce
qu'elles viennent pas chercher la
personnalisation et après il y en a
d'autres qui vont se faire des modèles
qui sont complètement délirant on va
avoir toutes les couleurs toutes les
matières toutes les rides tous les mets
tout sur les chaussures des chaussures y
en a qui s'amusent et d'autres astuces
sommes donc défense permet d'intervenir
quand même de dire parce qu'on contrôle
vraiment toutes les commandes donc des
fois on dit écoutez il ya énormément de
brides
êtes vous sûr peut-être aller plutôt
vers la ou vers la rue mais bon après le
client est roi elles font vraiment ce
qu'elles veulent on leur interdit rien
mais on intervient vraiment quand il ya
énormément de choses avec des conseils
stylistiques bien évidemment
la paire de chaussures et elle sait
plusieurs métiers c'est le patronyme
piqueur qui va découper les pièces les
patrons plan est ensuite assembler les
pièces de pau qui vont constituer la
tige la tige étant le dessus de la
chaussure
c'est ce qui va venir enveloppé et
recouvrir la forme donc la pièce blanche
c'est donc le gabarit de couple
patronage et donc on présente la peau
sur cette table de couper en coupe avec
une lame de coupe qui s'appelle
chassepot parce que quand on termine
d'avoir coupé une partie on chasse le
petit morceau de peau avec la pointe de
coupe
une fois que le travail de tiges et
réaliser on passe à ce qu'on appelle le
travail de pied c'est donc le montage il
s'agit de deux mètres les renforts à
l'intérieur de la tige de galber le cuir
la peausserie sur forme et enfin de
poser la semaine sachant que pour une
femme on travaille avec des méthodes de
trains sous des collets et pour le
travail d'homme on va faire avec des
coutures très pointe des coutures se
mêlent donc des opérations qui sont un
petit peu plus longue
au niveau de la réalisation l'outil qui
sert attendre le cuir est une pince à
monter donc c'est une une pince avec une
mâchoire qui sert à pincer la matière
première
tendre sur forme et c'est une pince qui
équipé avec un petit marteau pour
planter les clous
le montage avec le martelage de la tige
on est en train de préparer le renfort
arrière de la chaussure le contrefort
qui va être positionnés à l'intérieur de
la tige avant de galber le cuir sur
forme l'objet du contrefort s'est
ensuite de conserver la forme de la
chaussure est de protéger le pied tout
en maintenant le pied à l'intérieur de
la chaussure et puis ensuite vous avez
la personne qui bichonne qui finit les
chaussures c'est encore une fois un
métier complémentaire car la chaussure
une fois fabriquer un besoin encore
d'être mise en valeur pour être livré à
la cliente
[Musique]
on peut porter mais il faut être très
confort aujourd'hui c'est le confort et
non fabricants et créateurs pensent à ça
et maintenant on peut être hyper sexy
tout en étant très confortables
on peut tout imaginer et tout est
possible et tous nos designers et
chercheurs agissent en substance qu'elle
sera la chaussure de demain aujourd'hui
ce qui se passe c'est un petit peu le
chemin inverse que celui qui incarne 10
à 15 ans et qu'on revient vraiment sur
les méthodes de fabrication qui sont
plus ancestrales donc pour moi la
chaussure de demain ce sera pas vraiment
dans les techniques de fabrication
ce sera dans l'utilisation nouvelle
porcherie aujourd'hui c'est vrai que les
cuirs imprimés sont extrêmement à la
mode et je pense qu'on a encore je pense
des belles choses dans ce domaine là en
utilisant des peausseries qui seront
encore plus original peut-être plus
résistantes et puis encore plus coloré
donc moi je pense que ça viendra de là
mais au niveau de la fabrication
on a la chance en europe d'avoir ce
savoir-faire là qui s'exporte dans le
monde entier donc je pense que c'est
encore là pour vraiment longtemps
[Musique]
donc là on a là une fosse 13 sur toute
la troupe devant de la sandale sachant
qu'à chaque fois quand on travaille pour
des ponts des collections pour d'autres
créateurs on est confronté aux mêmes aux
mêmes contraintes c'est à dire que les
gens ont des désirs particuliers en
fonction de justin choix de matières
premières du type de piqûre qu'on va
être amené à faire des doublures
on rentre vraiment dans le dans le
détail de plus subtil au niveau des
tiges pour réaliser
les chaussures et les internets
vous avez bien tout suivi
récapitulons donc les étapes successives
de la création d'un modèle de chaussures
sur mesure en tout premier lieu on
effectue un tracé sur papier du contour
du pied du client ou de la cliente
à partir de cette esquisse on réalise
alors un premier moules en bois de hêtre
ou de charme qui représente déjà le plus
précisément possible la forme définitive
de la chaussure une ébauche de
chaussures est ensuite testé sur le
client ou la cliente afin de vérifier si
le modèle nécessite de nouveaux
ajustements
ce travail de fabrication du moule est
effectuée par le fournier c'est le
patronyme piqueur qui prend le relais
c'est lui qui dessine le patron plan sur
papier puis le découpage indiqué et
reproduit sur les pièces de port réel à
l'aide d'un outil appelé chassepot les
pièces recouvrant le dessus du pied sont
ensuite assemblés sur le moule en bois
avec une pince à monter c'est ce que
l'on appelle le travail de tiges
vient ensuite la réalisation du modèle
définitif après avoir travaillé la tige
donc faite aux monteurs de placer les
pièces de renfort intérieur de galber
l'epo et enfin de poser la semaine c'est
l'étape dite du travail de pied une fois
la chaussure entièrement bâti son allure
et perfectionner et des matières sont
mises en valeur avant d'être remise au
client ou à la cliente
enfin quelques chiffres clés un escarpin
effet d'un assemblage d'environ 40
pièces de pau le processus de création
dans son entier représentent 30 heures
de travail pour une paire de chaussures
pour femmes et 40 à 50 heures pour une
paire de chaussures pour hommes
pour moi c'est incontestablement and the
queen qui a fait le plus excentrique à
sa maison racée centric temps contre cet
été on a vu dolce donc pourquoi est-ce
que je suis dolce parce que dole à des
semelles sculptés en bois avec des
motifs sicilienne ensuite peints dans
des couleurs totalement joyeuse et il
utilise beaucoup de paille et je trouve
que dans les collections cet été où il y
avait beaucoup de classicisme les
collections qui s'en sort son dolce pour
ces raisons que j'ai adoré être à daf et
du minium et liste un peu japonisante
ça va sans doute être portées mais ces
chaussures joyeuse sculpté à la main de
dolce gabbana qui m'ont vraiment attiré
est-ce qu'on peut associer le confort et
les centristes et ça dépendra également
sur à quel point c'est son truc à il y à
aussi il faut être très clair il ya des
filles qui ne souffre pas donc il ya des
filles qui parlent morphologie et elles
ont des pieds parfaite je ne sais pas
quoi elles vont de la chance
elles peuvent porter n'importe quoi donc
ces fameuses chaussures sans talons
elles peuvent durer quinze minutes là
dessus les autres donc nous les mortels
on souffre dans les centres
le premier nom qui vient à l'esprit
lorsque l'on évoque l'excentricité dans
la mode et plus particulièrement dans la
chaussure est inévitablement alexander
mc queen l'enfant terrible de la mode a
tellement fait couler d'encre à propos
de ses créations que nous l'évoquons
forcément de façon régulière
c'est pourquoi nous prenons aujourd'hui
le parti de présenter des modèles de
chaussures les plus fous mais en nous
penchant uniquement sur d'autres
talentueux créateurs beaucoup plus
discret soft world news est une
collection de souliers fabriqués par
irma brugman nous parlons bien de
souliers en bois mais ici pas question
d'avoir mal aux pieds en effet c'est en
constatant le recul des ventes d
authentiques souliers néerlandais face à
la déferlante fashion que irma brugman
décida de leur donner un nouveau souffle
en les modernisant et surtout en les
rendant tout à fait confortable grâce à
une conviction intérieure calquée sur la
basket une autre créatrice néerlandaise
suzanne port
diplômé d'une académie artistique en
design de produits s'est spécialisée
dans la chaussure artisanale elle
confectionne elle-même à la main la
totalité de ses modèles nous voyons ici
une de ses premières réalisations
inclassable croisant les codes de la
ballerine de l'assemblage et de la botte
fondé en 1992 par les designers anglais
la speed et michael zoeller la marque
allemande très fun se réclame d'un style
caractériel et sensuelle la créatrice
encensé par la critique marleau stand
rumeurs produit des chaussures
provocante et d'un autre monde
elle a pour but de renouveler la
chaussure à travers la technique
ce modèle carbone est fait de simplement
entre pièces de fibre de carbone si le
premier commandement du glamour dans la
chaussure pour femme et de deux voire
amplifier les courbes du corps
les modèles de cette designeuse
commettent un péché très grave
rome les vanderberghe et s'est fait
remarquer depuis des années dans le
milieu du design pour ses créations aux
formes souvent anguleuses et froide
mais récemment c'est avec ses sculptures
en bronze qu'il a fait parler de lui à
priori en rupture avec son style
habituel
on peut tout de même le concevoir comme
une continuité vers toujours plus
d'abstraction dans un style plus concret
et exotique ses talents aubergines et à
la banane nous viennent de l'artiste
islandaise
nina torah rinse de tir ils font partie
de sa collection 2010 ils sont réalisés
en bronze school est directement
inspirée de l'essence des années 60 leur
avant gardisme et leur idéal de la
conquête spatiale
le designer guitares pop vient de
concevoir ce modèle en cuir et
polyuréthane dont on doute fort qu'ils
puissent être portées en présence de la
moindre attraction gravitationnelle
voici une paire de souliers tout droit
sorti de l'imagination de renate wolberg
étonnamment baptisé et mentale on se
demande bien pourquoi
et encore dans la série sans commentaire
voci wit it is de kiev kershner
fondateur de l'entreprise de white list
qui produit également des publicités et
des courts métrages noter le petit parti
en guise de provocation supplémentaire
enfin l'artiste japonais polyvalent
chausse imsa à réaliser en 2012 la
collection jouer un deuxième classe
culture qui comme son nom l'indiqué vise
à contraindre les formes de la chaussure
à des silhouettes réaliste envers le
plus souvent celle de faune marine ou de
flore haute en couleur ou
[Musique]
oh
vous travaillez des matières très
original vous nous en parler
par exemple enfin pas forcément la plus
originale mais c'est une des dépôts qui
permet de faire de très jolies
chaussures donc c'est la peau de
crocodile
vous avez ensuite des choses un peu plus
amusantes comme les po2 de crapauds par
exemple donc ça on peut faire des petits
empiècements sur des sur des plastrons
vous avez aussi la peau d'autruche
donc on est bien d'accord que ce n'est
pas une peau d'autruche
mais la patte d'autruche peut être
utilisé et puis c'est extrêmement variés
en fait vous avez une galuchat vous avez
les alors après pour les plus courantes
les chevreaux les agneaux les veaux
sachant que pour ainsi dire toutes les
peaux stan le serpent le poisson il ya
vraiment c'est extrêmement variés je
vois que vous nous avez apporté quelques
modèles vous avez des anecdotes à
raconter sur ces modèles oui on botte
une boîte elle qui est plus qui est qui
est peut-être un petit peu plus amusante
et et inattendue donc tout temps tout en
crocodile avec un un talon qui a été
fait en forme de lame de couteau
réalisé par un coutelier d'art donc ce
qui est plutôt amusant donc
effectivement c'est pas la botte qu'on
va porter à la ville mais c'est plutôt
intéressant à faire
quelle est la commande la plus originale
que vous ayez eu à faire bonne question
c'est tellement variés je pense que
cette chaussure qui était pour le
carnaval de venise était une des
chaussures extrêmement original une
chaussure que nous avons nous avions
fait pour une dame qui partait au
carnaval de
venise et qui avait besoin d'une
chaussure pour être très très grande où
il y avait beaucoup de couleurs et là
nous l'avons fait avec une couleur un
peu plus sobre mais voilà c'est des
choses que l'on fait est qu'elle est la
matière que vous préférez travailler le
la première fois que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure le croco extrêmement
souple ça fait des chaussures très très
joli j'ai eu l'occasion faire des
chaussures homme avec ses pots ça donne
tout de suite une connotation un peu
particulière c'est c'est au demeurant
très très joli et une chaussures pour
femmes en coco est juste somptueuse un
escarpin danse est une pure merveille
c'est sur ces paroles de professionnels
que s'achève notre numéro spécial
d'histoire de souliers consacrées aux
chaussures inclassable excentrique et
sur mesure
nous espérons que vous en avez appris
autant que nous en ce qui concerne le
processus de fabrication sur mesure et
les probables tendance du futur
à bientôt pour une prochaine histoire de
souder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]